Can you be good without God? Do you need to believe in God to know morality?
Does the existence of a moral law point towards a moral law giver?
Or can morality be explained by evolution?
These are some of the most common and yet important questions we can ask.
In Romans chapter 2, the Apostle Paul says that even people without the law
know right and wrong because it's written on their hearts.
In other words, part of being human is that we know there's a moral law.
In fact, we know it so clearly, says Paul, that God can judge us based upon it.
So in Romans chapter 1, Paul says that creation points towards a creator.
And now in Romans chapter 2, he says the existence of a moral law that we know
clearly points towards a moral law giver.
Let's take a minute and flesh this out.
When developed, this is referred to as the moral argument for the existence of God.
Now keep something in mind before we look at the particulars.
We're not saying that people have to believe in God to be moral.
We're not saying that people have to believe in God to know right from wrong.
Atheists can be moral. Pantheists can be moral.
Christians can be immoral. But we are arguing that if there is an objective moral
standard then there must be a God.
Think about it. You can read a book if you don't believe in authors.
All you need to do is know how to read.
But the question is, can there be things such as books if there's not authors?
And the answer to that is obviously no.
Similarly, people can be moral if they don't believe in God.
That's not the interesting question.
The question is, can there be a real right and wrong objective morality if there is
no God? The answer to that is no. In
his classic novel, The Brothers Karamazov, Russian novelist Fyodor Dostoevsky famously
said if there is no God all is permissible in other words if there's not
a transcendent moral source outside of human beings then well anything goes
the late atheist philosopher Friedrich Nietzsche said if there is no God then it's
those with power who get to determine right and wrong.
In other words, if God doesn't exist, then it's those with the biggest guns who get
to determine morality.
So here's the moral argument for the existence of God stated more formally.
It has two premises and a conclusion.
The first premise is if there are objective moral values and duties, then God
must exist. So what is it about morality that points towards God well for one
moral values and duties aren't physical you can't weigh them they don't have
extension in space they can't be studied by science moral values and duties contain
information commands about how we are supposed to live they point towards a source
outside of mankind instructing us about how we're supposed to behave there's something
about moral values and duties that has a spiritual core the
second premise is that objective moral values and duties exist
now how can I make such a claim well two reasons for one in his classic book The
Abolition of Man C.S. Lewis famously pointed out that across cultures throughout the
history of the world there's a commitment to certain universal moral principles
that justice is better than injustice that courage is good that we ought to care
for our children and our posterity now as Lewis points out how we practice those
moral principles might vary across culture but there is a universal agreement and
commitment to the underlying moral principles second people simply
know that there's a right and wrong we all live as if we believe
morality is objective. My dad often has said to me, he said, son, you know
what people believe about right and wrong?
Not by what they say, not by what they do, but by how they want to be
treated. Everybody wants to be treated as if promise keeping is an objective feature
of the universe. So I often tell my students, if someone says to you, there's no
such thing as objective morality, cut in front of them in line.
And what are they going to say? That's not fair.
That's not right, as if there's a moral standard that we're all supposed to
follow.
A few years ago I sponsored a public debate with three of my high school students
and three students from the public school free-thinking atheist agnostic club.
They debated the historical Jesus, intelligent design, and morality.
One of my students got up there and said there is an objective moral law, we know
it. Therefore, there's a moral law giver.
Morality points towards God. Then one of their students got up there and said, there
is no objective moral law. In fact, morality is all subjective.
It's like picking an ice cream flavor.
You have your moral truth and I have mine and we all live accordingly.
And then he sat down. Then when it was time for the concluding speech, instead of
summarizing why he thinks that their team won, one of the free thinking students got
up there and this is what he said he said you Christians are bigoted hateful and
intolerant shame on you for the way that you live I sat there and I thought wait a
minute just moments before he said morality is subjective it's entirely
individualistic and there's no objective standard then he got up there and he says
you Christians have violated every single moral norm shame on you, you
should have known differently. You see his worldview said there's no such thing as
objective moral values and duties but he couldn't live it out consistently.
Simply put this argument shows that the best explanation for the existence of
objective moral values and duties is that there is a personal God.
Now this alone doesn't prove that the Christian God exists.
It raises challenges for both pantheism and naturalism, but broadly speaking it's
consistent with a God of Judaism and a God of Islam.
What this argument shows is that the physical world is not all that exists.
There is a spiritual and a moral realm.
There is a God who cares about the way that we live.
There is a God who will hold us accountable for how we live our lives.